in recent years we've seen some movies
that really speak two different
generational points of view and vantage
points but you quickly point out not
enough the studio's I'm making mostly
big tentpole pictures or sequels
pictures that they can be sure of and
when a picture like this comes along
there aren't too many who will take a
chance on it Rob took a chance on it but
when you have such a pedigree you have
Michael Douglas Academy Award winner you
have Diane Keaton Academy Award winner
their first time together mark andres an
Academy Award nominee who wrote the
script and of course Rob Rob Reiner who
also an Academy Award nominee who's done
some of my favorite pictures of all time
when I read the script for the first
time I was just bowled over and like I
just did again I read the script and I
cried and I laughed at the end I said I
have to do this and I immediately called
castle rock and Rob Reiner and I said
we're making this picture and he said
great and from there on in it was all
hoping that everything that was in that
script I'll Rob Ryan of possibilities
combined with a great talents of these
two would translate on the screen and I
hope you all agree with me I think it
has the script and Mark Andres wrote was
for Jack Nicholson and Mark had written
the script as good as it gets and
remember i'm sure many remember Jack
Nicholson's performance the role of Oren
little was edgier more dislikeable
unlikable if you will and it took a
longer time for the audience to begin to
warm up to him in the script I view that
as a potential problem when Rob came in
and took it over Rob rewrote the script
to make it a little more heartwarming a
little less
edgy in the beginning and a little more
let's say reachable and attainable for
audiences because he was afraid that
maybe the role of Orin little as
originally written might turn audiences
off and it would take too long to get
them on his side so if that was a
pitfall I think he overcame it I talked
with Michael about Diane and he said he
said you know what's great about working
with her is you never quite know what
you're going to get he said I would lean
in for a scene and suddenly there would
be something that would just come over
what she would do is before a take she
would listen to music and then just as
Rob said action she would take her
earphones off and play and it was always
a little different there was always
something improvisational about it i
mean the the line where she's going off
to bed with with michael for the first
time she says i'm leaving my brawn that
just came you know it came out of it you
know it was so natural a woman of that
age who it doesn't want uncover totally
yet and her drinking of the wine that
was all her idea too and she would
always come up with little things i mean
this this is Diane you never quite know
what you get but you always get
something that's special and it's almost
always a little different and Michael
whose performances would generally be
the same because he's he's very very rid
rigorous if you will in knowing his
lines and getting the right he would
play off of her and so also many of the
delicious moments in the film came
because they always had a little
something different going and they
adored each other and I assume still do
that's very and do you have hopes of
doing another film like this now that
you've seen this one eight or nine times
my first hope is that this one is a
success you always take chances on a
film that is thank you a film that is
aimed for a very specific demographic
and listen initially that demographic is
is for the baby boomers and older it's
for those who still hope that something
wonderful can happen in their lives what
I didn't say was how this all was born
um when rob was doing bucket list with
Jack Nicholson Rob asked Jack he said he
said okay what's on your bucket list
what would what would you still like to
do and Jack said I'd like to have one
more great romance and Rob stood Wow and
he talked to mark Andrus and Mark
Andrews wrote the script and this is
what the movies about that no matter
what age you are love is love and it can
happen any time or if you you had it
like I have with my wife for 40 years I
mean that that love has been great but
so many people are not that fortunate
later in life to continue to have a
loving relationship and this film the
idea is that it gives hope to people
that there's something yet great that
can come in your life